Tsai: On behalf of
the entire YouTube API team,
I just want to welcome you guys
to "Powered by YouTube."
This is our first ever
API developer event
here at the YouTube office.
Um, my name's
Christine Tsai.
I'm part
of the YouTube APIs team.
And, um, I'm your resident
housekeeper for the day.
Um, we launched the APIs
back in March,
and since then,
you know,
we thought it would
be really great that--
you know, the community
is one of the biggest features
on YouTube.com that we think
really makes YouTube special.
We thought "Hey, we could bring
that same community
"to developers,
and, you know,
"really get the word out
about our APIs,
"educate developers on,
you know, what exactly
"you can do
with the APIs
in bringing YouTube
to your users."
So, um, this event
is kind of like our, you know,
first step in really spreading
the word.
Um, before we get started
with Hunter,
I wanted to give
a quick shout-out
to our office hours staff.
Office hours is the area
you saw in the lobby
with the signs.
Um, these are
our friendly TAs.
They're all members
of the developer ops
or engineering team.
I'm gonna let Stephanie Liu
give you a very quick spiel
on what office hours
is all about.
Liu: Hey, guys.
So if you look
at the back of your badge,
you'll see we have
a pretty packed agenda today.
But if at any point,
you want to wander out,
or, uh, you know,
get your hands
on some of the stuff
that you're hearing about,
we'll be outside.
Um, we're all engineers that
work with outside developers,
or some core engineers
as well.
My name's Stephanie.
And we have Jochen,
Geoff, Ryan, Jeff, Max,
and John will also be around.
And anybody you see in one
of these shirts will probably--
you know, you can approach.
But we'll be
the ones outside.
Um, but yeah,
if you want to--
We have some one-sheeters,
we have some, you know,
sample code
to get you guys started.
You can ask us questions,
we can probably do
some demos for you,
things like that.
So at any point,
come outside,
we're pretty friendly.
Tsai: Great.
Thanks, guys.
And with that,
I will hand it off
to Hunter Walk.
Walk: Hey.
That's right, clap!
[applause]
Um, so thanks, Christine.
Uh, so there's
my way-too-big picture.
Let's get rid of that.
There.
Um, so yeah,
so as Christine noted,
this is the first
developer day,
so, uh,
appreciate it,
because what YouTube
really is--
and I lead
product management here--
What YouTube really is,
it's a platform
for people.
And so I think
what we've always believed
from day one
is that, um,
it's not about trying
to pick what content
is gonna
be successful,
or trying to, uh--
trying to sway
the community move
in a certain way.
It's just providing
a platform
where people can upload,
share, and create.
And extending that offsite,
I think,
is really part of our--
part of our DNA.
And so what started
with the embedded player,
you know, sort of the ability
to kind of grab a YouTube video
and put it
anywhere you want,
has now evolved into the APIs
that you see in front of you.
And I hope for folks who aren't
as familiar with the APIs,
that they have the chance today
to learn a little bit more.
For folks that
have been using them,
I'm sure you won't be shy
about finding people
in gray T-shirts
and telling them
exactly what you want to see
from the next version.
Um, so I'm just going
to spend a few minutes
talking a little bit
about what YouTube has
to offer
to you guys.
Uh, and then,
a few tips and trends
that I've sort of seen
in our API development.
Uh, and then we can get
into sort of some of the meat
of the technical discussion.
So the first thing
that I believe YouTube has
is of this incredible corpus,
right?
So in fewer
than three years,
it's the most diverse,
the broadest,
the deepest collection of video
that you've ever seen.
Um, in fact, we now get
more than 13 hours
of new video
every minute.
So that's
an incredible amount.
It's about
20,000 hours a day.
Uh, I was doing sort of, like,
back-of-the-napkin math,
trying to compare
the productivity
of the YouTube user base
to traditional media.
And so that's the equivalent of
if Hollywood was releasing
57,000 new full-length films
into theaters each week.
And, just like Hollywood,
some of those YouTube videos
become quite popular,
others are more sort of
your niche independent,
uh, and some
are just plain weird,
and, uh, God only knows
why they exist.
But we celebrate them--
We celebrate them all.
And what does that mean?
It means that
no matter whether
you're creating an application
that's focused
on a very specific idea,
or just trying
to broadly appeal
to, um, you know,
the internet community,
we have a corpus
for you to program from.
So I was checking out--
We have over
200,000, uh, Madonna videos.
Uh, quite exciting.
In fact, when she released
her new album, she, you know--
Some of these celebrities now
are starting to film things
exclusively for YouTube
to try to sort of reach out
and talk
to the YouTube community.
And I guess she was
on the set of her video
with Justin Timberlake.
And she was vacuuming,
and sort of, like,
"Oh, hey, YouTube," you know,
"you caught me off guard"
type of thing.
And, uh--and then she's like,
you know,
"I want you guys
to keep uploading videos,
you know, singing my song,
and Madonna videos and stuff."
And we all kind of looked,
and, like,
"She just didn't tell everybody
to start, like, you know,
ripping and uploading
Madonna videos, did we?"
Like, "Somebody let
her record label know."
But it turns out that, um,
they were all
really cool about that.
And I think what we're seeing
is sort of an evolution
where folks are getting
more and more comfortable
with, um, different ideas
of relationships
between creators and fans.
And so that's
really exciting for us,
and, um, allows us
to continue sort of enabling--
bring people
closer together.
So 200,000 Madonna videos,
in case you want to create, uh,
a Madonna fan site.
But maybe you have
a very particular interest,
such as the sport of,
uh, wife carrying.
[laughter]
And if that's the case,
I'm not here to judge you,
that's cool.
Uh, totally,
do your thing.
Uh, apparently, there's
a few hundred other people
who are really
into that too.
And, uh, thus,
uh, don't--
You know, don't worry
about going out and trying
to commission, or find,
or sort of scare up video
to create that--
to create that dream site
or that dream application.
Just start borrowing it
from YouTube.
But what's interesting
is there's some things as--
as niche and,
uh, interesting
as wife carrying might be,
there's some things where--
I'm sad to say--
YouTube still doesn't have
enough video for you guys.
Um, fingerstaches.
So if you don't know
the fingerstache,
the story
of the fingerstache
is there's literally
this guy who got a tattoo,
uh, of a little moustache
on his index finger,
so that, I guess, you know,
right at the opportune moment
when he's talking to you,
he can kind of go like this.
[laughter]
Um, and as compelling
as that is,
for some reason, we only have
six fingerstache videos.
Um, so either we have a bunch
of fingerstache videos,
and they're just
not properly labeled,
or that quite hasn't caught on
in the YouTube community yet.
So I'm sure within, uh--
before the day is up,
somebody out there
will have created,
uh, a fingerstache
YouTube app.
And, uh, by the time
I check this later today,
you know, maybe we'll have
60 or 600.
So besides an incredible
corpus of video
for you guys
to draw from,
um, we have a community.
We have a community
that can--
um, you can both deliver
content into,
but that you can also use
to make aware
of what you're doing.
So YouTube's community,
if it was a country,
would actually be the third
largest country in the world.
Uh, we would probably have
a very strange-looking flag.
But I think what's
just incredible is, uh,
maybe even more so than
any other internet property,
I think we have the chance
to make the entire internet
into YouTube's user base.
Why?
I think exactly what
we were talking about before.
Sort of the breadth
of what goes on here,
but also the reach.
The fact that in order
to encounter YouTube content,
you don't have to come
to YouTube.com.
In fact, uh, each, uh--
Each month, videos are viewed
on more than 10 million
websites, blogs,
uh, social network profiles.
And that's in large part
to a lot of the amazing work
that folks like yourself
are doing.
How to take
the YouTube experience
and bring it outside
of YouTube.com.
A little bit later today,
uh, Brian Glick will talk
a little bit
about how the YouTube.com
experience is evolving.
Um, but I think
what we've really seen
is that the YouTube experience
evolves not just because
of what we do,
but because
of what you guys do.
And I think one
of the biggest changes
in the last few quarters,
as I look back
and sort of think
about where we were
last year
and where we're going,
is that experience
is not just web-based anymore.
So I don't know
how many folks in this room
are, uh,
application developers,
or have been working with,
um, various maybe, uh, hardware,
um, or other solutions.
But increasingly,
the YouTube experience
is not limited
to the PC.
So the general promise
of YouTube
is that for the first time,
the user is at the center
of their media experience.
And that media experience
tends to be a blend
of mass media, right?
So music videos, other things
that are generally popular.
Niche media,
and personal media,
things that are just being
shared by family and friends.
And so whether
you're looking at, uh,
the mobile, uh, devices,
or, increasingly,
the living room.
Um, whether it's capture,
or things like, uh,
the Flip video camera,
or delivery streaming
through set-top boxes,
increasingly,
YouTube is out there.
And, uh, we really want
to figure out
how to continue
to help you guys
take advantage
of that footprint.
Because especially what
we're seeing from consumers,
is that sort
of a "powered by YouTube."
A YouTube,
you know, YouTube-enabled
is a real great driver
for demand and adoption
of new devices.
It's a use case
people understand.
"Oh," you know,
"why do I need a new camera,
"or why do I need
a new phone?
"Because I can upload
easily to YouTube?
Sounds great."
So before I let
you guys go,
and get into a little bit more
of the technical discussion,
I want to talk a little bit
about three API trends,
and, um, hopefully how you guys
can take advantage of this,
uh, to create even more and more
successful applications.
Uh, the first is redefining
exactly what is video
and what can be uploaded
to YouTube.
So a few years back,
YouTube--
I think one of the reasons
they succeeded
was easiest way
to get a video file
off your hard drive
and onto the web.
Um, but to some extent,
sort of that basic feature,
the upload button,
you know,
has sort of become a commodity,
right?
You can find that
a lot of places.
And so I think one
of the reasons
that YouTube continues
to succeed,
and why our, uh,
content contribution
continues to grow
from the community
is we're now focused
on making it easier and easier
to get content--create content
right from devices.
So what you see here
is a screen shot
from, uh,
the video game Spore,
uh, Electronic Arts
is putting out.
Uh, you guys may be
familiar with this.
Will Wright, the guy
who did "The Sims,"
one of the best-selling games
of all time,
has now taken it up
another level,
and you can, uh,
essentially create a creature,
uh, and inhabit
a whole world.
So building buzz
for the game,
they brought out
the creature creator, right?
So this was sort of like
a creature modeler.
You can play--and they're
actually running
a really cool contest
on YouTube
where you sort of
make your creature dance.
And, uh--
and you can win.
So what they did
was use our upload API
directly in
the application itself.
So with one click,
you start doing screen capture,
and can upload
to YouTube
using your user name
and password
without ever
even leaving Spore,
or without ever having
to come to YouTube.
So before as where you thought
that the output
of, you know,
a video file
would be something
that came from a camera.
Now, more and more,
you can think,
"Wow, anything people are doing
that I can capture,
"and turn into a file,
and upload
is something
that people want to share."
And of course, this turned into
a lot of creative, uh, things.
You may have
heard about sporn,
um, which is, uh--
Let's just call them
genetically enhanced,
uh, creatures.
Um, I won't go into it.
If you haven't heard it before
and you're interested,
just search for it
on YouTube and you'll see.
But, uh, if you have kids
in the room, hide their eyes.
Um, the second trend,
uh, anthropomorphic dogs.
No, it's actually more
about how to make use
of YouTube's community
to build your application,
to build your community.
So what we're seeing,
of course,
is lots of people who want
to put content into YouTube
directly from their application.
Uh, this is, uh, Dogbook.
Uh, a dog community, and, uh,
has a Facebook application.
And you can upload there
directly from Facebook.
But what we're seeing
more and more,
are people making use
of the presence on YouTube
to help drive
awareness and traffic
back to their application.
And that's great,
we love that
bidirectional aspect of it.
What are some ways
you can do that?
Um, well, obviously,
you can sort of
insert metadata
and tag the source.
You can put a URL
into, um, the metadata file.
You know, "created on
www.url.com,"
and it allows
the YouTube community,
as they find your videos,
to go and then experience
your service
in the context of the way
you're building it.
So I think that's
gonna be some place
where folks who love
to do sort of, you know, like,
A/B testing
and other things...
we don't know
all the answers yet.
You're probably
gonna find out
what's the best way
to make the YouTube community
aware of services outside
of the YouTube.com world.
Um, but we definitely want
to support that.
Uh, and the third are
really, really innovative
and interesting, uh,
displays of the,
uh, YouTube content.
So one things we know--
one thing we know
is that, um, there's no way
that YouTube.com
can help users find all
the content they're looking for
in all the ways
they want to find it, right?
So for instance,
I always joke
that I'd love to see
a view of content
that sort of shows me
what was, uh, you know--
sort of the time machine.
What was on, uh, TV when I was,
you know, eight years old?
Or what were things that
were filmed on this date?
Um, and, you know, we try
to make all these things
come to life.
But with a corpus
that's just so large,
a lot of these needs
are going to be met
not on YouTube.com,
but outside.
Uh, and so this is a cool
application called "TimeTube,"
from a start-up,
uh, Dipity,
which, uh,
using the API,
plots for particular concepts,
uh, videos along a timeline,
as well as relative, um,
priority and relevance ranking.
And so this is, uh,
the history of "Chocolate Rain."
Uh, and, uh,
all started with a dream,
and then, uh, became, uh--
became a phenomenon.
So, uh, in wrapping up,
basically, I think
the storyline here is that
YouTube is built
on openness.
Uh, we succeeded
because we took a first step
when not a lot of people
were thinking
about pushing content out
across the web,
uh, with our embedded player.
And since that time,
have tried to move quickly
to push more and more
of that into the APIs.
Uh, I think one
of the most interesting features
that we've done this year
is the chromeless API,
that Jeff will do a little bit
more of a talk on later today,
which basically says "Hey,
here's just a video stream,
"build whatever application--
whatever player you want
around this."
Um, but at the end
of the day,
the magic isn't gonna come
I think
just from the tool set
we enable.
It's gonna come from what
you guys do on top of it.
So, um, if anything,
I hope today is sort of
a call to action to inspire you
not only from
what you hear from us,
but from talking
with one another.